valhalla
that is where i am assassin's creed
valhalla is the viking experience you've
been waiting for
if what you've been waiting for is an
immersive open world in a beautiful and
authentically gritty 9th century setting
full of epic tales told on long ships
huge siege battles
challenging enemies dangerous boss
fights and dogs who need to be pet
valhalla has evolved the assassin's
creed series with an amazingly
customizable new combat system
powerful skills a long ship load of new
enemy types
and a huge dark age landscape to
experience it all in
with the ability to customize your
warrior avor
your clan your longship and even your
settlement it proves to be the best
viking simulator around
here are 10 ways that assassin's creed
valhalla really nails the viking
experience
9th century europe was a mess of warring
kingdoms and religions
as the vikings explored westward from
their scandinavian homelands they
established themselves across a wide
swath of europe
you play as avor in valhalla taking an
active role in shaping some of the
actual events that changed history such
as making kings and displacing old ones
here i'll resign it here
join forces with real historical figures
like the sons of ragnar lothbrok evar
and uba
not only are you immersed in history you
can change your present with what you
choose to do
your choices influence the outcome later
in the game
do you have what it takes to be king
should you let the guy you just defeated
live or should you kill him he may come
back to seek revenge but that might make
things more interesting later
the roman empire was already long dead
by the time the viking longships landed
on english soil but the crumbling ruins
of their once great civilization are
all over the landscape in valhalla
adding to the feeling that this place
existed
long before you came to chop off dude's
heads with your axe
if you're like me heading off with your
crew to burn down and loot a stronghold
is one of the greatest joys in life we
were born a thousand years too late to
enjoy
as avor you blow your horn to call your
longship full of your viking clan
members and take command while you raid
your enemies
singing and telling stories during the
journeys between battles
once you arrive at the castle fortress
abbey or town you busy yourself with
battering down the gates knocking down
doors taking enemy siege weapon
positions and finally getting that fat
loot for your clan
valhalla has the most varied set of
enemies in any assassin's creed yet
and the combat in valhalla stays fresh
and challenging because in addition to
the complex tactics from regular enemies
you encounter
there are dangerous new advanced enemy
types trying to separate your viking
head from your viking body
all the time for example regular troops
using their shields to fend you off can
be made vulnerable quite easily when you
destroy their shield but yalemen have
thick
shields that require you to get around
their flank to attack them
skirmishers are quick dagger wielding
combatants who dart in to attack and
then dodge away
shooting them in the knees slows them
down enough that they can be dealt with
i've only played a small part of the
game but so far i've encountered
multiple enemies who are like mini
bosses themselves
or so i thought until i fought an actual
boss
the boss fights in valhalla are super
challenging and each boss brings
different tactics to the battlefield
forcing you to adjust your play style or
get cut in half
also many of the characters in the game
really existed in viking history and to
me this adds another layer of immersion
to the fight while capturing the mercy
and king bergrid who was an
actual king who was deposed by the
vikings avor can't use
weapons or risk damaging the royal goods
on the bright side fist fighting an
armed combatant is a great way to learn
to dodge
leo is bergrid's loyal captain who
wields a long sword
a wicked backhand and an angry charge
ability
i used my bow on his weak spots before
chopping him down with my axes the type
of viking you are in battle is dictated
by your weapon of choice and in valhalla
you have many weapons to choose from
dual wielding is a new addition to the
assassin's creed series and it adds
another layer to the already deep combat
in valhalla should you use the classic
double axes allowing you to go berserk
on your enemies hacking at them until
you tire out or maybe mix it up with a
hammer to smash through their shields
before chomping at them
each weapon type comes with its own
finishing move i personally like the
spear but the two-handed axe is pretty
devastating as well
each of the three different types of
bows can change your range
game the fast firing light bow to
unleash your inner legolas
the mid-range hunter bow to adapt
quickly to any situation
and the precise predator bow to murder
from a distance
in valhalla the skill tree is a highly
customizable web that allows you to fine
tune
avor to your playstyle personally i
favor the melee damage route and
upgraded heavily into that creating a
berserker who tries to kill the enemy
before they can kill me
as you continue down each path new
abilities become available that vastly
change the way that you viking
the rush and bash ability allows you to
charge an enemy and bash them into a
wall
dive of the valkyrie launches you into
the air bringing down swift justice in
the form of an axe to your opponent's
head
and to finish them off axe throwing fury
tosses axes at every enemy and range
sealing their fate if you're a ranged
player piercing shot allows you to shoot
an enemy through walls
and focus of nor near slows time so you
can take a bit more precise aim at their
soft spots
as you complete quests and win fights
you gain skill points but exploring can
earn you books of knowledge which can
expedite the process
as a viking gambling seems to be as
common as getting drunk and in valhalla
you can
gamble on how fast you can get drunk
there are numerous games to bet silver
against your skill
the drinking contest is a rhythm game
with the added element of trying to keep
your drunken body from falling over
the dice game has deeper tactics than
just rolling dice
and the rhyming trash talk competition
called flighting might actually make you
both a better poet
and better in arguments i'm the greatest
of flighters a master of verse
your pride is appalling and your rhyming
is worse
between battles making history drinking
and gambling there's still a trove of
side quests and activities to keep your
viking hands busy
i fed a really weird woman snake egg so
she could
wreak havoc upon her above ground
enemies
fought in a viking fight club took
hallucinogenic mushrooms and
communicated with seals
and crushed a little kid's dreams
this is all in addition to other very
viking stuff like
leaving offerings at altars to the gods
and solving ancient puzzles
the way you look can drive fear into the
hearts of your enemies before you even
have to lift your axes
you can customize avor to be the viking
you want to be with tattoos
haircuts and equipment from the merchant
but it doesn't stop
there in your upgradable settlement
which acts as your hub
you can customize your ship at the
shipyard your clan members and even
create a customizable viking warrior for
hire that you can build in your game and
share with your friends in their game
so your friends can have a unique
addition to their crew to assist in
destroying their enemies
the huge open world of valhalla is both
beautiful and dangerous
looking out over the vast expanse during
sunset is one of the most gorgeous game
visuals i've ever seen
and getting kicked by a deer knocked a
reminder into me that even nature was an
enemy in the 9th century
taking a moment to listen to the
musician in your clan's longhouse is
just as transportive as watching drunk
peasants beat each other in a street
fight
valhalla's environment will make you
feel as much like a viking in the dark
ages
as possible without time travel valhalla
will make fans out of any newcomers and
the new skills and updated combat system
will make the game a
perfect evolution for lovers of the
assassin's creed series
assassin's creed valhalla will be
available on november 10th on xbox
series x and xbox one
it's optimized for xbox series x
supporting 4k resolution at 60 frames
per second and it leverages smart
delivery allowing access to both xbox
one
and xbox series x titles when available
write your viking saga on xbox series x